-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're in the same room.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, it goes without
saying, but we're living through
a pretty crazy time right now,
but luckily it seems like
some things are getting
back to normal.
Watch this.
-A JetBlue pilot was removed
from the cockpit of a plane
in Buffalo because he was
suspected of being drunk.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
After he blew into
the breathalyzer,
it didn't even say a number.
It just said "new high score."
[ Laughter ]
Cool.
It's amazing -- it was the first
time a flight attendant
had to duct-tape a pilot
to his seat.
[ Laughter ]
He was so drunk,
he refused to leave
unless he could go
down the slide.
That's what he was saying.
[ Laughter ]
I guess it was pretty obvious
something was going on
after the pilot's
first announcement.
Listen to this. We got footage.
-[ Hiccups ]
[ Hiccups ]
[ Can opens ]
-Interesting.
That's frightening.
Guys, this is going to viral.
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
saw some high school students
at his press conference
who were wearing masks,
and he wasn't too happy
about that.
Watch this.
-Alright, well,
it's good to be at USF.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Gross.
Students were like, "Somehow you
make our principal seem chill."
[ Laughter ]
When their parents asked how
their day was, they're like,
"I got bullied...
by the governor?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, as Vladimir Putin
continues his invasion
of Ukraine, I saw that
Netflix has paused
all of its
future projects from Russia.
It's a little weird without them
in the next season of
"Queen's Gambit."
They're like, "you're playing
the world's top chess master.
He's from Staten Island."
[ Laughter ]
He's the best in the world.
[ Applause ]
Then also today, IKEA announced
that it's closing all 17
of its stores in Russia.
IKEA said they'll do
whatever it can to throw
a useless tiny wrench
into Russia's economy.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it bends. It bends.
It bends? It's supposed to bend?
Get this -- even Spotify has
closed its office in Russia
and removed all Kremlin-backed
content from its platform.
Yeah, well, we finally found out
what it takes
to get kicked off Spotify.
[ Laughter ]
And it's not just businesses
distancing themselves.
I read that
the International Cat Federation
has banned Russian cats
from all competitions.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just going to go ahead
and say that's the biggest news
that's ever come out of the
International Cat Federation.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the silence
from the International Dog
Federation is deafening.
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't it be amazing if this
is what finally breaks Putin?
He's like, "Enough is enough.
I draw the line
at cat competition.
They work all their lives to
compete, some almost nine lives.
And look at this."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
I saw that
"So You Think You Can Dance"
is returning to TV
after a three-year hiatus.
A lot of people are excited.
Here, check out this promo
they just released.
-Maybe you thought "So You Think
You Can Dance" was in the can.
Well, think again because we
think you can dance,
so "So You Think You Can Dance"
is back.
So it's time you think
"So You Think You Can Dance"
is back too.
So you and we can all dance the
can-can kinda so-so
On "So you think you can dance
can dance dance
think so dance can.
You think?"
"So You Think You Can Dance."
Does anybody else smell
burnt toast?
-I mean, the guy's losing it.
He shouldn't do voiceover.
Some more TV news --
Next year HBO Max will begin
streaming U.S. soccer matches.
[ Audience cheers ]
Of course, since it's HBO,
every match will have
full frontal nudity.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man was recently
pulled over by police,
and he had a very creative
excuse to try
to get out of a ticket.
Watch this.
-Florida man really wanted out
of a traffic stop,
but deputies in Flagler County
were not expecting
this excuse for speeding.
He blamed it on Vladimir Putin,
saying he was speeding home
because of a nuclear war.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't worry.
Despite the arrest,
the man was able to keep his job
as a pilot for JetBlue.